so rights health care college free
income
free you name it and you don't lose
those rights
even if you rape and assault your next
door 14 year old neighbor
it's what the founding fathers what of
one day
so samantha let me be very honest with
you i believe
that a in a democratic civilized society
health care is a human right
government should make them got a drink
[Applause]
i believe that every young
person in this country this just shows
you that bernie sanders has no idea as
to what a fundamental
human right is a human right okay by the
way is something constitutionally which
he's
he has no concept of it's pretty clear
is not granted to you by government
otherwise any commodity goods or service
could be could be a right just like in
germany to declare the internet to be a
human right
no human rights are inalienable rights
that are given to you by god
and they are simply recognized by
government things like freedom of speech
freedom of assembly freedom of religion
the freedom to self-protection the
second amendment
health care is not a human right college
is not a human right and by the way
you know how else you know that he
doesn't understand the concept of human
rights the only way you
forfeit basic human rights which are
given to you by god
as a birthright is when you irreparably
harm someone else
like in the incident of a violent crime
or some kind of a serious sex offense
and by the way he doesn't think those
people should forfeit those rights to
vote
and elect him your next president while
they are currently serving in a maximum
security prison
so rights health care college free
income
free you name it and you don't lose
those rights
even if you rape and assault your next
door 14 year old neighbor
it's what the founding fathers
from bernie's own website he says that
he wants to re-enfranchise the right to
vote to the 1 in 13
african-americans who have had their
vote taken away by felony conviction
paid their debt to society
and deserve to have their rights
restored i i'm actually curious about
the rest of the people
who are felons but apparently it will
only apply to african americans the one
in
here's something actually an interesting
legal question i was thinking about this
earlier there should there are different
classifications of felonies certainly
correct
so there should be obviously i don't
think that if let's say for some reason
at some point you got caught with a bag
of cocaine or crack or meth i know
they're gonna say it's racist if you
don't say crack i don't necessarily
think you should
lose your right to vote for all time but
i do think if you're a violent felon if
you're a sex offender and again that's a
different degree of felony you shouldn't
have a say in the laws that we create if
you're going to blatantly
disregard them in a way that harms other
citizens absolutely i mean
whether you call it a social contract
whether you look at the utilitarian
practical aspect
of giving someone like that the right to
vote again and
granted it's going to be a small
minority but in any particular place i'm
really thinking of californians i mean
they're going to have the largest
problem with this
if that vote to right to vote is
re-established um it just won't really
change the voting block a whole bunch
of you they're all the same california
went from blue
to really blue
oh yeah voting to register sex offenders
nice
sounds like a plan question goes to this
being like you're writing an opposition
ad against you
by saying you think the boston marathon
bomber should vote
not after he pays his debt to society
but while he's in jail
there it is you know this is what i
believe do you believe in democracy
do you believe that every single
american 18 years of age or older as an
american citizen has the right to vote
no it's only 30 stars
he's giving new meaning you know you've
heard that description of democracy it's
five wolves voting to eat a sheep
yes you've heard about that he's really
talk he's actually talking about wolves
he's talking about people who are in
prison for violent crimes who should
vote while they're in prison
i i thought here's the thing i actually
think it's an interesting conversation
to entertain
if they've paid their debt to society
and it is not one that directly involved
uh inflicting harm on somebody else and
i know that all crimes inflict harm on
somebody else because you're a burden on
the taxpayer but it's different from a
violent crime or sexual assault or
something like that
certainly he's talking about people
who've harmed other people who are
currently in maximum security prison
voting
when you've got cuomo looking at you
wide-eyed in disbelief
hey there if you like this video this is
the part where i would usually tell you
to subscribe but
i can't do it anymore i'm going to tell
you to subscribe and then youtube is
going to decide that
we can't reach you even though you
subscribe to this channel and then i'll
say hit the notification bell
and then the notification bell won't
even be there anymore
i don't know what to say more than
likely you'll find my face in a milk
carton but do what you can to stop it
it's just it's just it probably won't do
much